two senators are calling for an
investigation into whether some
companies use deceptive tactics to help
people by influence on social media
according to the New York Times a number
of businesses are selling millions of
fake Twitter followers to celebrities
and other people paper says some of the
followers are the stolen identities of
real users and other people who do not
exist at all
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with how officials
are taking action vlad good morning good
morning you might be impressed by the
number of followers of some of your
favorite celebrities sports figures and
politicians but how many of those
followers are the real thing there are
companies devoted to giving anyone new
followers at a price and now there are
questions about whether that practice
constitutes fraud so many people follow
this promotional video for Twitter
highlights the importance of followers
on the social network but according to a
New York Times report followers have
become so valued that people are willing
to pay for them whether they're real or
not Dan Ackerman is an editor at scenic
most of the time the fake followers are
what we would call bots they're their
artificial people they're either created
from a database of names and photos or
they're automatically copycatted from
real accounts just with a slightly
different name one company that's come
under scrutiny is DeVoe me it promises
to accelerate your social growth from
trending tweets to viral videos we make
it happen they have a bunch of packages
listed you could start with just 500
followers for $10 and they'll get you
those within a couple of days The Times
analysis found that DeVoe me draws from
an estimated stock of at least three
point five million automated accounts
and at least 55 thousand of the accounts
use the names profile pictures home
towns and other personal details of real
Twitter users including minors on
Tuesday two senators sent a letter to
the Federal Trade Commission asking them
to investigate the deceptive and unfair
marketing practices by davu me and
similar companies New Yorkers deserve to
have their identities protected the New
York State Attorney
general's office has also opened its own
investigation what sort of answers are
you looking for from de movie we want to
know what they were selling we want to
know what their procedures were and how
they did it
Daboo Mies founder denies his company
stole social identities or sold fake
followers he told the New York Times the
allegations are false and we do not have
knowledge of any such activity still the
Chicago sun-times pulled reviews by film
critic Richard Roeper after allegations
he bought twenty five thousand to view
me Twitter followers Roper did not
return our request for comment if you
are a person on social media or an
influencer who buys a lot of these
followers then you turn around and sell
your services to a brand or a company is
somebody who's important in social media
the people you're working for it might
feel like they're paying for something
they didn't get a popular person who's
really only followed by ghosts
in a statement Twitter told CBS this
morning the Bumi's alleged tactics
violate our policies and are
unacceptable to us we are working to
stop them and any companies like them to
VU me did not return our request for
comment it is interesting though when
you log on to its site and now try to
purchase Twitter followers the website
says the service is unavailable I mean
this is advertising fraud you have
people who are selling themselves as a
brand to companies to make money and
there's nothing there ghosts as was said
in the piece the Attorney General of New
York says that the Internet is the
greatest tool for democracy but it is
being destroyed by this opaque
pay-to-play system that creates an
alternate reality Thank You Vlad it's
great play